we're gonna get started first of all
with writer executive producer Jon
Favreau and director executive producer
Dave Filoni okay this is our first
live-action Star Wars television show
can you guys talk a little bit about
what is so appealing about that to you
guys as somebody who grew up with Star
Wars and and really having been formed
around what I experienced when I was
little with the first film there was
some aesthetic to it that I that I
really that I really gravitated to and
my whole taste in movies was probably
formed in a big way from seeing George
Lucas's original film and and I learned
about cinema through through the lens of
that film because my father would
explain to me know that's you know this
is this is a lot like samurai movies so
this is a lot like westerns or world war
two films and so that became my inroad
and then there was a whole power of myth
with Joseph Campbell and Bill Moyers
that was filmed up at the ranch and that
opened me up to the mythic structure and
the monomyth and my understanding of
mythology and storytelling and so to
come back and return to this with the
freedom that this new platform affords
because there's nothing to compare it to
nothing has been on TV other than the
holiday special and and and the the idea
of telling a story over more than just a
couple of hours told every few years
opens us up to this novelization of
story and a return back to the roots in
many ways of the Saturday afternoon
serial films that my parents generation
grew up with I just found the whole
thing exciting I think as a kid growing
up you watch Star Wars you think I would
watch this every week and as television
got more and more into genre over the
years and like I remember when Star Trek
next generation came out and the promise
of better visual effects on television
and it took big leaps and you know as
somebody that's always been into fantasy
science fiction you were always waiting
for a moment where you thought that what
the images on television were as good as
what you were seeing in the theater but
there was a big separation on as a kid
and now I think it's gotten so close and
you know it's one of the thrilling
things we can make something like Star
Wars because technology has advanced and
it's that's one of the dreams of the
George had even when I worked with him
on Clone Wars he would talk about the
future being streaming the future being
episodic see realized
Star Wars because like you said it's
what influenced him so yeah and it is
cool to get to help make it so please
welcome Pedro Pascal Gina Carano and
Carl Weathers
how you doing Pedro did you get some
sleep or just power through hello what
was the moment you realized I'm truly in
the Star Wars universe
Pedro what was it for you well putting
the helmet on for sure which they had
handy at our first meeting and to see if
it would fit it fit perfectly and and
and and and I guess you know very simply
trying the costume on for the first time
in looking in the mirror you can't see
very well to them helmet but but I got I
got a pretty clear impression and if you
grow up you know playing with Star Wars
toys and obviously seeing these movies
and then you're staring at yourself and
and and and and you are the image of of
that kind of childhood imagination it's
a super pinch me moment quote me exactly
super pinch me is that a hashtag super
pinch super punch
hashtag super pinch Mandalorian
I think for for me it was my first day
on set seeing the whole costume come
together and John and Dave came and you
know they made such a big deal out of my
gosh look how great you look and I was
like wow this is really great but it
really honestly was one of my my
favorite unforgettable moments being in
on set seeing the the other cast members
but be it behind a helmet or creature or
or this one and then actually my first
day on set I was on a blur so I was up
on this this big thing and I was just
like okay this is this is it this is my
life now Wow and and John did John did
sort of a slow roll on me it's like it's
like okay I've got this thing that I
won't want to talk to you about and okay
and first of all I mean I'd met John so
we had a lot of interaction even though
it wasn't like really personal personal
stuff but we'd had a lot of interaction
and I really admired him and I'm sincere
about that I really admired him because
this guy is super smart ridiculously
smart about much more than just making
movies so that was number one so I'm
fascinated and I'm saying okay that
those are the kind of people I want to
be around and know so I can maybe blood
grab grab something that he's got that I
really admire but anyway you know that
the thing is when when when we finally
had the meeting about it and not unlike
Pedro tells us story when you walk into
that room that conference room and all
this art is on the walls and he is so
passionate about it all and it's all
magnificent I mean it is some of the
most beautiful art work you could ever
see if you were a collector you want to
go through and take pieces off the wall
because it's that beautiful and then
started telling me basically what this
was and a little about this character
and it's like are you kidding me
I'm working on something that Disney is
going to be behind I'm working on
something that Jon Favreau is like
marshalling through and I'm working
on a Star Wars kind of invention and
then I get a chance to meet Dave Filoni
and now it's like we're in good hands
we're in really good hands so that that
was my introduction and I'm happy to be
a part of it there are a lot of themes
that you guys have pulled in I don't
miss anybody so Bryce Dallas Howard
Taika Waititi Dave Filoni I mean can you
talk a little bit about what their
contributions are and it's Dave's first
time directing live-action long-overdue
Rick family Uwe also did a couple for us
and don't forget Debra Chow and Deb Chow
of Morris she's a Joe who's going on now
to do the obi-wan Kenobi show so Sara so
she came in to start so this is really
you're gonna see I think a lot of people
that are working in this incubator of
story and technology and and start you
know really people who got together
because they love Star Wars and this I
think enthusiasm that seems to be very
contagious not just with the people on
the couch here but the artwork he's
talking about you know that's Doug Chang
who's been part of a lot of people who
came up through the ranks over the years
since the prequels and and all of them
slowly like Tom Sawyer coming together
to paint the fence and there's this real
enthusiasm that's very organic as we're
telling the stories and it's a very
collaborative environment you know we we
talk a lot about story and and I write
most of it but that's just a jumping-off
point for the directors to be very
involved and very collaborative and all
the people who are involved whether it's
ILM or Lucasfilm are within the Castro
mandalorian and so it becomes this
really fun collaborative thing that
takes on its own life and own
personality and I think you'll see with
each of the directors unlike a lot of
television the directors are really
being given an opportunity to have
authorship over it as though or a film
so it's been very exciting for us to
have that kind of environment to come to
work to every day John you posted a
photo of of George Lucas and yourself on
set can you talk about that experience
who was on set that day would you talk
about Karl was there that day I think
Gina
was there that day I know for sure I
know for sure this guy was there because
I met Dave because I was up at the ranch
mixing iron man and he was secretly
working with George on Clone Wars before
anybody had ever heard of it and I
showed him iron man
he showed me Clone Wars I was like if
you ever need a voice on this I'd love
to do it which turned into me playing a
Mandalorian named Pre Vizsla on his on
his show but what's so nice is that
George had worked with him for what 10
10 years and so they had worked together
so a lot of what's wonderful about
working with Dave is that that
continuity of vision this has been a
real special thing for me it's something
that I really doing live action I became
interested in it from working with
George and the way that he talked about
how we should shoot Clone Wars and he
would always speak in live-action terms
the terminology was always around but
and I didn't always understand how to
apply it over the years though I got a
little better with it and he's so
steeped in technology George and pushing
technology previous systems stuff like
that on Clone Wars that it just became a
part of the language of FileMaker for me
as well and working with John is really
natural it kind of continues that
because he's very forward-thinking with
technology and using tools to help
enable greater storytelling and I saw
that you know in Jungle Book just
incredibly so very inspirational II and
with the work that he's done in Lion
King and whatnot so for me it was a
great opportunity to work with somebody
that kind of works in a similar vein but
I could really be challenged and John
has challenged me I will say that
creatively storytelling wives and you
need that sharpening you need to improve
and and continue a legacy of big you
know frankly being mentored I see it as
very Star Wars this whole path for me
well I think at this point we're gonna
open it up to the audience here hi
Congrats guys they looked amazing thank
you for John and Dave you mentioned
Taika Waititi he's obviously also
voicing a character
show can you talk about what he brings
to the show what it's like to work with
him well you know when you bring in a
director like tyka that he's clearly
doing it because he wants to because the
guy is just such a powerhouse right now
creatively and I think everybody's
really discovering what a talent he is
people who follow comedy knew about him
long ago or independent film and now
he's just he's really enjoying a
wonderful run and so when he shows up it
gets everybody excited because it's a
fresh energy on the set he finds
opportunities for humor he brings his
style of humor to it but he also is a
fan and that was that - to me that was
the bottom line
prerequisite you had to love Star Wars
and you had to want to do you want you
had to want to do something great and
helped invent this new thing and to have
tyka in there as somebody who was a you
know battle-hardened veteran who could
come in and just has tremendous
instincts and to work with the actors
and to bring that for me you know to
just be able to work with him I had
known him for a while and from the
Marvel world we had been sharing
experiences that we had had but to
actually be on the set and to witness
what he did was was tremendous and then
and then to have him play the do the
voice of IG 11 and bring that specific
tone to that character but also the tone
to what he directed was fantastic I'm
grateful to him for that first of all
congratulations on the show the footage
was awesome
I'm curious the making of the first
season of any show you're learning the
infrastructure of how to put it together
what you can accomplish in the timeframe
etc except for for each of you guys what
did you learn making season one that you
are now putting into season two medicine
out every day and I think for me one of
the things is I mean I was on set every
day the whole season so I learned
watching every single one of our
directors I learned watching our great
cast
everyone behind the scenes I treated it
as you know boot camp for me to learn
this type of filmmaking but then I tried
to offer the knowledge that I'd been
passed on to me by George for Star Wars
things and just the way that he liked to
shoot things but it definitely has
affected the way I look at you know a
day
what can I accomplish in a day that's a
big difference for me filmmaking wise we
arrived on a back lot and the DP Craig's
like well the Sun's up we gotta get
going I'm like alright cuz it's gonna go
down
animation we don't really have that
problem so you know you're getting on
six o'clock and everyone's getting
squirrely and you're like the sun's
going down the sun's going down like
right then we're screwed and this saw
whole sets going down so there's there's
a bunch of very tangible things that are
gonna happen and you know it's I love
having this experience and knowing the
difference between animation their
advantages and disadvantages to each one
I don't frankly at this point prefer one
or the other I like both experiences and
they're both unique but I do love and
I've talked about Cathy quite a bit
about this as she's asked me of the
differences that I've experienced
there's something about the concrete
nature of live-action it's incredibly
spontaneous it's gonna happen right
there in the moment and then that's it
where I can tweak a tiny eyebrow or a
tiny smirk or give a Sokka just a little
bit of a push in a direction that will
dramatically change the character you
have to get all these variables to kind
of come together and be aware of it and
it's not like you're controlling any of
it as much as you're guiding it and you
know John Wood what stands me and speak
this you know you're looking at
everything all at once
we're in animation it's like a recipe
that I can keep adding little greasy you
have a lot of flexibility thank God and
digital and post we can do a lot but
capturing that moment right in front of
you I think the real magic of it all and
something that up and craving to try and
luckily we have an incredible crew and
cast that can capture those moments as
hopefully you saw in the footage but
yeah that's what I learned the most I'm
so I wanted to ask you teasing the
footage
the mandalorian never takes off his mask
so when are we going are we going to see
it and I think do you really want to
know that do you want to come we're
wrapping Christmas presents wrapping
Christmas presents your real question is
do we ever take off our masks
you know stunt doubles are essential to
every large production just so you know
like even for the strongest people or
agile ones so none of it can get done
without the incredible stunt work I mean
especially what did you guys see today
like 27 minutes or something you saw
like a whole clip you have no idea the
amount of star power from every
department that goes into making
something like this from you know the
person that is like you know working on
the shine of my shoulder to the person
who built the entire ship that we're
shooting on or the whole set it's it's
I've I've I've seen some I've seen some
I've seen some pretty big I haven't seen
anything like this so I noticed the
footage we saw there were a lot of
references to the Star Wars Holiday
Special like and of course that's where
we saw our first Mandalorian yes so can
you talk about why you wanted to throw a
draw that connect those little dots I
didn't realize there was a lot of I
guess there is
well definitely was the gun right that
the the the pulse rifle just cuz but
here's the thing I I wanted to have it
we're starting with new characters right
everybody there there's all sorts of
conjecture as this really when he is it
is it is it gonna really reveal that it
will its boba fett all along is it a
character we already know we wanted to
start fresh with a whole new group of a
whole new set of characters that you
never met before and so there are ways
that even though we have new characters
and you could jump in because it's
chapter one we wanted to make sure that
if you are watching and you knew about
it and this is where dave has really
been a treasure trove because we we try
to effort to work stuff in whether it's
humorously like making a reference the
life day or a reference to a prop that
has been has been appreciated by a core
group over time just putting those
little easter eggs in or big movements
in the story that reflect storylines in
either the legends or in canon that
people have known and had and by the way
all of the animated content that had
that Dave's been working on how do you
leave all of it together so that you
don't have these divided segmented parts
of the you know of the audience but you
could start to bring it all together and
coalesce it in a way that creates an
overarching narrative and rewards the
people who've been putting the time in
over the years since they were kids
growing up with it John write these
scripts turn around we would talk
sometimes does that be in Sanford says
he will be on the phone and we just
start rallying and come up with a whole
plot for an episode kid you not on the
phone and he's like okay it's in my head
I gotta go I gotta go boom okay and then
like a day later here read this I'm like
oh wow
there's a script now and it was cool I
mean it's really fun and it's fun
reading you know John's take on sorry
I would read something like I think the
holiday specials back and I give him a
hard time about it
you know cuz well it happens I'd read
that right yes I know it's a long way of
saying you really like the holiday
special and I've expected that it's fine
there's nothing wrong with that we know
you have the gun in this show because
you liked it and you wanted to have it
the cartoon now it's in your office and
I get that like I've never experienced
that before like you say I want to
design this I'm gonna have this and then
someone literally makes it walks up to
you enhance it to you I haven't had that
animation that's what's that's what's
been really great about it and there is
a discipline about it of like let's make
sure that we are authentic disciplined
cohesive and that no matter where you're
coming from and what your background in
Star Wars you know that what we're doing
is not being done it's being done out of
we've really deliberated over it and
discussed it and thought thought it
through
and so if we depart in any way it's it's
we know we are and if we but it's with a
plan and part of it also is what's the
big arc you know that's the other thing
that's the fun thing is the plan and
like there are some things around like
people are gonna think of this but then
we think about what you're gonna think
about it and then we will see because
you might know this move but you don't
know that move and that's just the fun
part especially in series yes we can
make that work even better you create a
dialogue yeah yeah well I think I can
speak for everybody when I say we'd like
a holiday special thank you guys thank
you guys for all your wonderful
questions thank you mandalorian Disney
Plus never ever talk
[Music]
[Applause]